nous reprenons nos travaux en
auditionnant cet après midi monsieur
patrick eveno je rappelle que cette
commission denquête a été constitué à la
demande du groupe socialiste écologistes
et républicains et à pourra porter david
assouline
monsieur ne vous êtes ici à plusieurs
titres tout d'abord comme spécialiste de
l'histoire de la sociologie des médias
où vous avez été professeur d'histoire à
l'université paris 1 panthéon sorbonne
vous avez enseigné l'histoire des médias
vous avez également travaillé à l'école
supérieure de journalisme de lille et à
l'institut pratique du journalisme de
paris
vous avez également commis des ouvrages
qui est dans l'un fait toujours
référence en 2012 histoire de la presse
française de théophraste renaudot à la
révolution numérique et vous êtes
également un acteur engagé puisque vous
avez dirigé la rédaction de la revue le
temps des médias et participer à de très
nombreux travaux relatifs à la presse
enfin entre 2019 et 2021 c'était très
récemment vous avez présidé le conseil
de déontologie journalistique et de
médiation la commission est donc
été très désireuse de vous entendre pour
écouter vos éclairages sur l'évolution
historique des médias à travers les
siècles et sur votre vision de la
situation actuelle je vous propose
l'organisation suivante comme pour
l'ensemble des auditions je vais vous
laisser la parole pour dix minutes pas
plus un propos introductif
et ensuite nous fonctionnerons sous
forme de questions réponses en
commençant bien sûr par les questions du
rapporteur et après tout toutes nos
sénateurs et sénatrices qui le
souhaitent pourront vous interrogez vous
pourrez développer des choses que vous
n'aurez peut-être pas eu le temps de le
dire dans votre propos liminaire cette
audition est diffusé sur le site
internet du sénat et elle fera également
l'objet d'un compte rendu qui sera
publiée enfin je rappelle pour la forme
qu'a faux témoignage devant une autre
commission denquête seraient passibles
des peines prévues aux articles 434 13
14 et 15 du code pénal je vous précise
également qu'il vous appartient le cas
échéant de nous indiquer vos éventuels
liens d'intérêts ou conflits d'intérêts
en relation avec l'objet de la
commission denquête je vous invite
monsieur eveno a prêté serment de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité en
levant la main droite en disant je le
jure je le jure je vous remercie et je
vous donne la parole donc pour dix
minutes merci alors je vous ai j'ai je
vous envoyer un petit parlez parlez bien
dans le micro pourquoi ils nous
entendent non seulement dans la salle
mais également pour nos collègues
effectivement puis avec le masque c'est
compris en plus je vous ai envoyé un
petit document
histoire de vous de vous donner un peu
le fond de ma pensée avec les parties
que je souhaiterais aborder pour moi qui
a
votre commission denquête comme
d'ailleurs celle qui a été menée par
l'igad kelly gf ya pas j'ai été
auditionnée aussi par l
excellente que j'ai été auditionnée à
plusieurs reprises par différentes
commission denquête aussi bien
sénatoriales que de l'assemblée
nationale
si yahia vous êtes dans un comment dire
vous êtes
votre commission avait été créée afin de
mettre en lumière les processus qui ont
permis pouvant aboutir à une
concentration des médias en france et
d'évaluer l'impact de cette
concentration sur démocratie le problème
que je je je maintiens depuis des années
et des années
après avoir passé plus de 40 ans sur
l'histoire des médias c'est qu' il n'y a
pas forcément de rapport
entre
ces deux termes entre concentration et
pluralisme pour cela je vous ai donné le
plan comment concilier la nécessaire
recomposition du marché des médias avec
la non moins nécessaire préservation du
pluralisme qui fait la démocratie je
suis un grand démocrate je suis pour la
liberté d'opinion et c est avec les
points suivants la concentration n'est
pas une question démocratique c'est un
problème etc annick
la liberté des rédactions est prise en
étau entre la nécessaire gestion par les
actionnaires et le nécessaire respect dû
plaire à lui du pluralisme de la
démocratie etc
et enfin le pluralisme est un enjeu
démocratique pas un problème
économique et c'est là où vous êtes pris
en étau en plus parce que ça arrive à un
moment où vous avez conjointement de
concentration qui se mène de front l'une
parfaitement classique de concentration
économique
tf1 m6 et rtl d'un côté et de l'autre
une concentration
enfin la première étant si je puis dire
une concentration défensive face aux
gaffes à face à la disparition d'un
certain nombre de revenus publicitaires
etc etc ce terrain concentration
défensive dans un secteur mur dont un
secteur vieillissant comme l'était la
presse à van avant la télévision mais
comme le devient maintenant la
télévision et comme l'a été l'automobile
ou assez dur j ai dans tous les secteurs
mur ou vieillissant il ya forcément des
disparitions et des concentrations il y
avait 200 producteurs d'automobiles dans
le monde en 1914 il doit y en avoir une
dizaine aujourd'hui bon ça fait partie
de des choses de la vie économique si je
puis dire je sais que vous n'êtes pas
d'accord monsieur assouline mais je suis
bon
voilà ça c'est le cc dans un secteur mur
c'est comme ça alors après on peut
discuter mais bon on peut discuter
évidemment des seuils de concentration
des tsé toutes ces choses là ils font
parler et puis de l'autre côté vous avez
une autre volonté
j'avais dire concentrationnaire mais là
c'était vraiment un peu un jeu de mots
mauvais
de concentration qui est une une
concentration offensive et politique
clairement politique je rappelle au
passage que si le soleil j'ai un seul
conflit d'intérêts avec scholes qui a
lancé le commission c'est que quand
j'étais
quand j'étais membre du du comité
d'éthique de i télé
avant que i télé ne vienne ne soit
racheté par bolloré et j'ai démissionné
au moment où de ce comité d'éthique au
moment où wall aurait a mis son ordre
dans i télé on va faire avec la manière
extrêmement brutale que vous connaissez
quand vous a raconté à plusieurs
reprises notamment mon ami vesco la
cchit donc bon il ya ya ya pas qu il n'y
a pas de problème là dessus on voit bien
que ces deux deux choses complètement
différentes deux choses complètement
différentes et qui font que on est dans
le brouillard
brouillard pourquoi parce que parce que
première chose et je vous ai mis un
petit dessin de faisans qui date de 1972
c'était pour vous amuser un peu parce
que c'est pas si je serai très gai que
nous avons devant nous mais on pense
avec son passé et voilà faisant dans le
figaro a marre 72 il ya 40 ans 50 ans
pardon pile poil
et c'est pas un journal d'extrême gauche
hein c'est pas faisant est pas reconnu
comme étant un caricaturiste c'est
pâques a bu un bon
et voilà voilà comment on pense la
concentration des médias c'est d'un seul
coup on va revenir toutes les rédactions
il y aura plus qu'une seule rédaction
qui dira la même chose à tout le monde
pour tout le monde bon or dans le même
temps je vous ai donné ensuite un petit
tableau où depuis quarante ans que j'ai
pris depuis l'arrivée de françois
mitterrand ou la fin de valéry giscard
d'estaing vous voyez qu'il ya une
multiplication considérable des supports
de diffusion de l'information
certain déclin de la presse écrite mais
une variété considérable de radio vous
allez tout à leur écoute et le sirti
donc c'est la même chose
une variété considérable de télévision
et puis internet qui évidemment
n'existait pas avant 1995 et qui se
retrouve maintenant avec des milliers de
sites avec des centaines de chaînes
youtube dont certaines dépassent
l'audience de beaucoup de chaînes de la
tnt
plus donc évidemment tous les réseaux
sociaux majeurs
donc
le point le premier point c'est quoi
c'est la concentration tf1 m6 c'est une
concentration qui est une concentration
vous avez qu'à voir le tableau suivant
extrêmement simple à comprendre
quelques chiffres j'ai intitulé ça comme
ça les investissements publicitaires en
france vous avez la télévision
- 14 % en dix ans à napanee la presse
-55% la radio -17% interne est multiplié
par quatre et si on prend le tableau
suivant si on prend les prévisions dans
le total publicitaires de ses quatre
médias 1 je parle pas de l'affichage des
choses comme ça la presse qui est passée
de 53 % du total à 12 pour cent du total
la radio de 9 à 4 ou 5 la télé de 37 à
25 % du total et internet de 0 à 50 8 %
du total même si une partie de la
publicité qui va sur internet et va sur
les sites internet des différents médias
s'est estimée à peu près à 9% on
pourrait même dire peut-être 10% mais
enfin bon on va pas chicaner sur les
détails mais vous voyez que encore une
fois les ce qu'on appelle les gars
femmes
sont actuellement perçoivent
actuellement près 50% du marché
publicitaire français donc évidemment la
fusion tf1 m6
avec 70% on veut peut discuter des des
des recettes publicitaires des recettes
publicitaires des de la publicité
gratuite
c'est évident que ça ça crée un
quasi-monopole
monopole voulue par le président sarkozy
lorsqu'il a amputé de 50 % la recette
publicitaire de france télévisions et de
radio france
mais bon ça c'est une autre histoire
c'était en 2009
et donc qui est un un quasi monopole
mais quand on compare aussi avec les
audiences vous avez les audiences qui
sont devant vous à tf1 largement baissé
france télévisions aussi m6 aussi ce
sont les autres chaînes qui ont
largement augmenté même si on prend
l'ensemble du groupe si on réunit tf1 m6
et la tnt des deux groupes on est à 40
7% d'audience en 2002 on est à 40 %
d'audience en 2020 et ça me fait penser
le rapport d'alain lancelot en 2005
qui disait il faut limiter l'audience à
la part d'audience à 37 5% et bien quand
le 6 le groupe tf1 m6
vent en deux ou trois petites chaînes il
retombera à 37% et il n'y aura pas de
problème d'audience bon
dernier tableau 1 les 40 premiers
groupes de presse français parce que
j'ai j'ai écouté beaucoup et j'ai lu
beaucoup des comptes rendus que le
confère aux administrateurs
on n'a pas beaucoup parlé de chiffres on
parle de concentration sans parler les
chiffres ce qui est quand même assez
étonnant
oui mais oui mais moi je suis je suis
d'efforts mais je fais j'ai fait
d'histoire économique
c'était ça mon point de départ bon et
donc je m'appuie sur des chiffres je
vous ai donné un tableau qui va sortir
la semaine prochaine dont les clefs de
la presse mais vous l'avez en avant
première c'est que la presse du 22
janvier 2022 il n'y a pas d'erreur sur
les 20 pour les 40 premiers groupes de
presse en france en 2020 parce qu'on n'a
pas encore les chiffres 2021 vous voyez
que c'est des tout petits mais c'est des
tout petits
le plus gros le groupe figaro 550
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
par an
ou est-ce france le plus grand journal
français 520 et ses accès on va pas
faire et quand vous arrivez au 40e qui
est un allemand burda on est à 29
millions d'euros alors qu'il fait 3
milliards d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
en allemagne mais bon ça c'est un autre
problème
donc vous voyez que ce que je veux dire
c'est que la concentration
ccq quelque chose qu'on a appelé comme
ça depuis
reversant depuis sa mort monte à 70 dans
les années 70 deux pics robert hersant
s'est emparée avant à la libération
parié des trusts
l'avenir c'est la même chose un bon les
traces le trust vers h est bon et c'est
à la pieuvre verte qui mangeait tout et
tout et tout mon les trusts il fallait
retirer la g j'en ai pour combien une
minute encore
oui moi laissez moi une minute alors bon
c'est une vision très très archaïque que
défendent un certain nombre de gens que
vous avez entendu
que j'ai lu aussi enfin bon bref je pas
vous citer lesquels mais il faut quand
même dire clairement que c'est un un
vieux débat
antilibérale il libéral je vais le dire
clairement
vieux débat
qui est que l'on considère que la
concentration c'est mal là pas de
problème la concentration ses mains
pourquoi c'est mal on sait pas on sait
pas parce que est ce qu'il y a un
rapport parce que c'est là ça serait mal
ça peut être m'en pour deux raisons
c'est monopolistique à ce moment là on
fait la jouer leurs lentilles monopole
et c'est pour l'antique ou ce qui va
être le cas quand bolloré si bolloré fab
bolloré va racheter lagardère et donc il
va se retrouver cachette editis
l'autorité de la concurrence va obliger
de conclure tout ça on va revenir sur
tout ce que vous venez de le dire avec
des propos assez fort donc je ne doute
pas une seconde que ça va susciter des
questions qui commencent à nous et je
pense assister beaucoup de questure et
mais j'ai pas eu le temps de mais vous
inquiétez pas en avant alors je vous
écoute
merci suivent nos se connaît de
multiples débats surtout lié s'était
d'ailleurs raison principale de cet
odieux de votre audition ici liées à
de combat long que vous avez menées pour
un observatoire
de la déontologie journalistique et
essayer de faire que sur la question de
l'information il y ait une auto
régulation de la profession comme il
peut en exister dans d'autres métiers
même si les choses sont très différentes
mais c'est c'est votre combat et c'est
beaucoup là dessus alors comme tout
citoyen vous avez des opinions aussi sur
le système économique dans le pays et
tout ça mais c'est pas trop là dessus
que
notre réflexion
se porte des vêtements même si vous avez
affirmé des convictions
notamment considéré dans votre
introduction que ce n'est qu'une affaire
économique et pas démocratiques la
question des concentrations et que donc
c'est la sphère de l'autorité de la
concurrence finalement que de juger si
tel ou tel rapprochement ou telle ou
telle fusion
atteint à ces règles mais bon de vous
vous pensez bien que ce qui est quand
même largement documenté c'est que les
concentrations parce qu'on ne parle pas
justement d'automobiles mais
d'information et d'une matière première
qui n'est pas une marchandise comme les
autres la culture et l'information que
des questions de monopole dans ces
domaines ont depuis longtemps par des
grands libéraux
qui ont fait la loi de 86
impliquées de considérer qu'il fallait
de la régulation démocratique pour pas
que l'ensemble des moyens d'information
puisse être concentré entre les mains
d'un trop petit nombre et donc dire que
ce n'est qu'un problème économique n'est
pas du tout dans notre tradition
démocratique au sens large du terme
c'est à dire l'ensemble des républicains
qui ont fait les alternances depuis 1980
dans notre pays droite et gauche
confondues
sur ce propos vous avez été et ça serait
intéressant que vous en toute franchise
et en ravivant votre mémoire vous nous
racontiez ce qui s'est passé au moment
du passage du télé à ces news et qui
vous a conduit à
la démission votre démission avec aussi
votre collègue
julie jolie julie joly maintenant
directrice du comité de déontologie du
groupe canal+
j'ai dû beaucoup de choses là dessus
mais votre récit m'intéresse et
notamment si vous pouvez nous en dire
plus sur les les conversations les les
rapports que vous avez eue avec le
groupe lui-même au moment de prendre
cette décision qu'est ce qui vous a
motivé et comment ça s'est passé
j'ai répondu tout de suite c'est pas
difficile à j'avais été c'était l'époque
où céline pigalle était directrice de la
rédaction de itélé est ensuite allé
passer à bfm mais j'ai démissionné un
peu avant pardon
est passé par l c'est effectivement et
puis ensuite à bf est maintenant et à
bfm depuis oui nous l'avons auditionné
il ya quelques jours je sais
donc
bon moi j'ai vu comment comment est
essentiellement j'ai vu comment la
réaction la rédaction réagit c'est le ce
que ce qui me semble très important
c'est la liberté des rédactions parle
souvent de l'indépendance des rédactions
je sais pas ce que c'est que
l'indépendance des rédactions puisque
par définition
les rédacteurs sont des salariés elle
est salariée sacré être salarié ça crée
un lien de dépendance vis-à-vis de son
employeur donc une réflexion
indépendante je sais pas ce que ça veut
dire un journaliste indépendant je ne
sais pas ce que ça veut dire y compris
un pigiste il est un salarié en revanche
une rédaction libre je sais ce que ça
veut dire c'est tout à fait différent on
parle beaucoup d'indépendance mais moi
je passe que un pays indépendant la
biélorussie est un pays indépendant vous
le savez tous comme moi bon donc il ya
pis ça ça veut rien dire l'indépendance
enfin la dépense des médias
la liberté des médias c'est quelque
chose d'important c'est la liberté
d'expression la liberté d'opinion et là
on en vient à la régulation ce que vous
avez dit sur la loi de 86 tout à fait
mais pourquoi ses réserves et à
l'audiovisuel et pourquoi spécifiquement
même à la télévision plus qu'à la radio
à la wii dans les délais les stater de
1880 à la loi du 29 juillet 1881 j'ai
fait plusieurs l'article là dessus aucun
jamais ils n'ont voulu faire un statut
de l'entreprise de presse ou faire une
régulation de l'entreprise de presse la
presse est libre points c'est ça que ça
veut dire la loi de 80 alors après eric
zemmour vient d'être condamné ce matin
par le tribunal correctionnel pour
incitation à la haine raciale et c'est
bon ça tout à fait c'est ça tombe sous
le coup de la loi 81 et c'est très bien
mais
jamais ils n'ont les législateurs de la
troisième république n'ont voulu faire
quoi que ce soit sur la règle et le
statut de l'entreprise de presse on en a
parlé pendant des années des zones et en
1928 s'abîme vous répondu à ma question
s'il vous plaît sur quoi sur ma question
était comment s'est passé pourquoi votre
démission parce que j'ai vu les
rédacteurs
de i télé
être
comment dire
quasiment obligé
d'accepter soit une télévision qu'il
n'avait pas envie de faire
soit la porte avec indemnités mais la
porte
voilà je les ai vus j'ai participé à
leur débat g etc je les ai soutenus et
le seul soutien que je pouvais faire
parce que ma voix n'a pas grande
importance dans l'espace public le
soutient que je pouvais faire et on
s'est concerté judy joly on a dit on
démissionne tout et on a fait un petit
communiqué en disant on démissionne
voilà bien c'est comme ça que c'est
parce que j'ai pris le parti de la
rédaction contre l'actionnaire mais
l'actionner en question qu'est-ce qu'ils
aient il est d'humeur doc un faut être
clair il faisait de la foxnews ce qu'ils
voulaient c'était faire d'une force news
à la française ou un équivalent
quelconque enfin on peut discuter sur
les détails et ça
moi personnellement j'estimais que sa
brutalité vis-à-vis de la rédaction
ne me permettaient plus de siéger
sereinement dans un comité d'éthique où
nous étions trois bons et donc on a
terminé à neuf ils ont lors constituer
vos avez eu à ce moment là
étaient frappées par des faits
d'intervention
je parle de faits l'intervention de la
direction ou de l'actionnaire pour alors
c'est vrai que vous dites qui a été fait
oui il ya toujours il ya toujours des
fesses qui c'est ça qui m'intéresse mais
oui mais c'est juste pour compléter la
question du rapporteur vous allez vous
avez dit l'actionnaire dans votre propos
tout à l'heure et a dit la rédaction et
directionnelle non mais il y avait là
l'actionnaire qui imposait à la
rédaction
ce que la rédaction ne voulait pas faire
c'est une véritable question qui pose à
la fois une question économique et
juridique et donc démocratique
est-ce que l'actionnaire a le droit
d'imposer une rédaction ce qu'il ne ben
là je suis évidemment moi profondément
choqué et c'est pour ça que j'ai
démissionné qu'ils aient eu d'effet
s'est défait qu'on m'a raconté c'est pas
des faits auxquels j'ai assistés j'ai
pas vu vincent bolloré dire un rédacteur
tu me fais pas si tu me fais ça je ne
crois pas d'ailleurs que vincent bolloré
le fasse et l'important pour lui c'est
de placer les bonnes personnes au bon
endroit c'est pas la peine de téléphoner
tous les jours à cyril hanouna pascal
praud pour leur dire de faire ce qu'ils
ont envie de faire ce qu'ils ont envie
de faire ils le font très bien sans
colorer et quoi que ce soit à leur dire
si steps de les augmenter de temps en
temps donc il n'y a pas de problème de
ce côté-là d'y aller vous voyez c'est ce
n'est pas là la pression de
l'actionnaire là bon alors
c'est c'est très compliqué le le
problème le problème il est fondamental
c est ce que
c'est vrai c'est christophe deloire nous
en a parlé l'autre jour
pluralisme interne depuis le pluralisme
externe
la loi de 1881 je suis dit 'ça 80 elle
dit
la presse est libre chacun peut créer
son journal donc pluralisme et externe
et donc on peut avoir des journaux
d'opinion et nous on répète tout on
répétait enfin moi j'ai démissionné lui
c'est l'hygiène parce que je voulais
récupérer ma liberté parce que ce que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure évidemment c'est
pas entendable par les journalistes donc
c'est donc j'ai voulu récupérer ma
liberté en arrêtant toutes mes activités
que j'avais mené pendant 10 ans et ça
suffisait comme ça
je passe à autre chose mais vous voyez
bien que
j'ai plus où j'en étais là la liberté là
le pluralisme interne pluralisme externe
presse l'externe pour la presse pas de
problème pour le de visuel parce que le
visuel a été nationalisée en 1944 parce
que le visuel jusqu'en 1981 quatre vingt
80 de la loi de 82 mais en fait 84 quand
on a créé les nouvelles chaînes et est
sous la tutelle de l'état et les restait
encore très très longtemps il fallut
attendre faut se rappeler quand même que
si tf1 appartint appartient bouygues
c'est parce que jacques chirac l'a voulu
il faut se rappeler que jacques chirac a
tout fait pour que hersant est la 5 la
première 5
avec berlusconi bon ça fait faillite et
tout ça et ça c'était de l'intervention
du politique 1 faut s'en souvenir de ces
choses là excusez moi je suis en des
temps alors je
une question qui en même temps rebondit
sur vos propos pour avoir votre avis
vous avez dit en gros
quand on a fait la loi sur la presse on
a dit la presse est libre points et à
partir de là
les journaux pouvaient se constituaient
les opinions qu'il souhaitait diffuser
aider et on a quand même à dos et cela
avec avec des droits des journalistes
droit de cession
clause de conscience pour si vous voulez
plus travailler nos tel cadre où est un
propriétaire et il pouvait le droit
individuel mais vous dites pourquoi avec
l'audiovisuel
c'est pas la même chose bien mais ça
peut pas être la même chose parce que
justement il ya eu un distinguo alors
peut-être y aura des évolutions le
distinguo l'a souvent discuté dans notre
commission denquête avec beaucoup d eux
d auditionner c'est que
le la fréquence est un bien public mais
qui est attribuée par une institution
publique et donc il ya une convention
qui est passé parce que c'est partout on
obtient le droit d sur la tnt par
rapport aux postulants il ya une infime
minorité s'est liée à la rareté même
qu'on pourra l'utiliser aujourd'hui deux
pas de là dedans et méo tous les cas de
l'offre possible et donc dans ces
conventions à aucun moment encore plus
sur les chaînes d'information il n'est
écrit que ce sont des chaînes d'opinion
c'est d'ailleurs la verse s'était créé à
chaque fois qu'il faut veiller à ce
qu'ils aient en pluralisme d'expression
etc parce que on n'a pas voulu faire
la chaîne l'humanité la chaîne le monde
la chaîne levée mais arrow la chaîne
valeurs actuelles n'ont cessé c'est pas
aujourd'hui comme ça que le csa travail
qu'il a
des impératifs disons donc voilà je que
pensez vous on à l'heure de cela et
comment faire respecter
7cette très relative particulière celle
différence particulière qui lie à entre
l'audiovisuel et la presse écrite
écoutez différence particulière je sais
bien que ce sont des fréquences qui
appartiennent à l'état que tu sais c'est
que c'est un bien commun comme diraient
certains biens publics ok ça n'empêche
que pour la radio par exemple c'est pas
pareil on à radio courtoisie on a su le
radio tranquille un droit dans leurs
bottes et on pourra en trouver il y
avait à un moment une radio anarchiste
puisqu'elle existe encore enfin bon
donc c'est pas l'audiovisuel c'est pas
la loi de 86 un bon vous voyez là il ya
des radios d'opinion et puis vous allez
avoir le sirti tout à l'heure donc je
vous laisse jouer savait que tranquille
pour ce qui est de la télévision ça a
été fait effectivement parce qu'on était
en 1986
et que on a continué après avec la tnt
mais maintenant c'est terminé c'est
terminé le pluralisme interne pluralisme
externe c'est fini le pluralisme externe
il est sur les chaînes youtube les
chaînes youtube berson plus d'audience
que que bfm tv ou que face à certaines
chaînes youtube donc elle s'en moque du
pluralisme interne complètement elles
sont dans le
vase y que je te pousse enfin bon ou
français de souche ou bien égalité
réconciliation la célèbre le célèbre
blog de de mr camus pas albert mais
l'autre
bon ils s'en moquent complètement du
pluralisme externe du pluralisme interne
eux et y vont à fond la caisse excusez
moi de l'expression donc les les chaînes
de télévision pourquoi pourquoi on
n'aurait pas maintenant la constitution
de ce que j'appelle moi le le blog de la
réacosphère bolloré n1c je trouve que
c'est une expression assez joli la
réacosphère bolloré nc très très bon
dans la
et alors et alors c'est surtout que
c'est des chaînes qui sont à très faible
audience si vous faites le total de
l'audience d'audiovisuel de bolloré il
ya 4 % pour europe 1 il ya 2 % pour ces
news il ya 2 % pour ces 8 il ya quelques
pourcents pour canal+ mais là c'est en
dehors du truc vous êtes à un seuil
extrêmement bas et donc si on veut
casser cette entreprise de réunion ou de
concentration eh bien il faut avoir un
seuil du
extrêmement bas qui va faire que plus
aucun groupe ne va pouvoir s'investir
dans la télévision parce que les seuils
seront tellement bas que moi et
heureusement les lois sont jamais
rétroactive donc ça cassera pas les
anciens groupes mais bon sait où on est
on est effectivement maintenant face aux
gars fin on est face aux réseaux sociaux
on est face au youtube heures à tout ce
que vous voulez c'est là où est mon
problème et c'est pour ça que moi je dis
qu'il faut c'est là le dernier point sur
lequel j'insiste il faut créer un
observatoire faut se situer dans à
l'intérieur du système que les européens
veulent mettre en place avec le le le
[Musique]
comment le média au freedom act now ou
le freedom of mediact sait jamais dans
quel sens et je suis mauvais en anglais
bon qui est en cours de négociation en
cours d'appel d'offres etc
il faut créer non plus un observatoire
comme je lé fais de la déontologie ou un
conseil de déontologie il existera
toujours il ya plein de conseils de
déontologie du conseil de presse dans en
europe y en a 21 rebonds le français 21e
c'est très bien mais il faut aller au
delà et c'est pour ça que je vais
proposer ce que je vais proposer à
l'union européenne la création d'un
observatoire européen du pluralisme de
la transparence dans les médias adossé à
une fondation européenne pour la liberté
de la presse pour la liberté parce qu'il
faut concilier la liberté et
l'économiser médias il faut que les
actionnaires puissent faire leur job
d'actionnaires quand xavier niel
dans 2012 2013 a dit aux journalistes du
monde non pas un truc sur les journaux
mais il faut pas fait les jeunesse du
monde voulait faire un pdf a envoyé le
soir aux abonnés
xavier elle leur a dit mais ça va pas la
tête non feinte puis il l'a pas dit
comme ça mais bon excusez moi je suis
toujours un peu
c
il a dit il faut il faut faire une
matinale sur apple parce que depuis cinq
ans vous avez des mobiles que des
applications et que les jeunes y sont là
dessus et que si vous voulez aller voir
les jeunes et non pas mourir avec vos
vieux lecteurs qui ont plus de 50 ans eh
ben il faut aller sur la matinale c'est
comme ça qu'ils ont créé la matinale
s'affairent aux jambes et dans la
rédaction mais ça a marché et maintenant
ils ont cinq cent mille abonnés dont
plus de 400 milles du méric bon
voilà bien nous sommes assez nombreux à
vouloir vous posez des questions tant
mieux je vais demander aux uns et aux
autres et moi compris du reste d'être
assez bref dans les interventions et si
vous pouviez aussi messieurs eveno être
assez bref pour que chacun puisse poser
sa question auriez mogodé
imaginons bonjour à toutes et à tous
cher monsieur mercier déjà pour la
transmission des éléments vous avez fait
parvenir
en amont qui était très intéressant et
vous avez je trouve bien poser les
choses et et montrer combien avec les
chiffres combien la télévision est un
secteur déclinant et pas dire que c'est
un crocodile empaillé mais un secteur
déclinant et combien un petit peu seul
le débat est un peu un débat d'arrière
garde quand on le pose tel que un petit
peu nous lui posons mais il faudrait y
voir véritablement soulan une telle que
vous présentez là contente concentration
qui est un phénomène effectivement
économique et du pluralisme il lui
enlève de la démocratie vous avez
souvent employé ce mot qui a été ô
combien de fois a employé la semaine
dernière alors que nous parlions du pass
vaccinale le fameux mot de liberté et
que c'est plutôt à c'est sous cet angle
là qu'il faut regarder notamment le le
pluralisme vous semblez esquissé dans
votre document et ça sera ma question
que je vais pas dire le remède à tous
nos maux mais en tout cas l'avenir
serait d'une une régulation européenne
est ce que vous pouvez développer un
petit peu ce point s'il vous plaît oui
je crois que il faut vraiment maintenant
situés dans l'europe parce que
on est on est plus
on est plus au 20e siècle on est dans un
système mondial où on voit bien que la
puissance et les américaines enfin bon
d'abord et avant tout la puissance des
gaffes ait été enfin bref on va revenir
et l'europe elle il faut qu'elles
qu'elles font les bases de sa de sa
femme qu'elle consolide pardon les bases
de sa société démocratique et la liberté
de la presse au sens large liberté les
médias la liberté des rédactions
sethos est consubstantiel avec la avec
la société démocratique
bon mais il faut que cela reste dans la
liberté de marché aussi c'est pour ça
qu'il faut réguler mais faire attention
à pas trop réguler faut pas créer parce
que créer une loi anti bolloré c'est pas
difficile si jamais vous y arriver il ya
eu la loi et entière semble en 1984 elle
a duré deux ans elle n'a jamais servi à
rien
pourquoi parce que parce que c'est les
lois de circonstance les lois à 2000m ça
ne marche pas bon donc oui il faut
passer à l'europe il faut passer à
l'europe faux moi je crois beaucoup
au faire savoir dire aux européens aux
citoyens voilà c'est pour ça que je
propose la création de cet observatoire
qui serait extrêmement large qui doit
être financé et qui peut s'associe au
conseil de presse et à tous les
régulateurs type art com etc regroupés
dans mal dans les regards et s'articuler
que les dna et dessins mais
un observatoire vous pourrez faire des
bases de données parce que maintenant
avec c'est extrêmement facile à faire où
il y aurait toutes les données des
médias est alors évidemment bolloré on
sait bien qui possède quoi enfin bon
voilà on voit bien qui comment ça marche
mais aller plus loin parce que c'est
cette absence de transparence
je crois que là la commissaire
européenne madame joue
avec moi excusez moi je suis j'ai oublié
ça va je vois qui c'est mais bon vous
voyez de qui je veux parler kike gens en
charge de cette cette idée de faire une
à une
media freedom act bon comme les états
unis l'ont fait sous johnson ou comme
l'angleterre l'a fait il ya 10 ans 15
ans bon
c'est quelque chose qui est et ça nous
permettrait de voilà d'aller beaucoup
plus loin dans et en même temps de
contrer et les îles libéraux de type
hors ban et compagnie qui sont
évidemment
très embêtant aussi pour nous
michel logis
merci monsieur le président monsieur no
merci pour vos propos et votre
enthousiasme est en tout cas bien de
rebondir sur ce que sur la question de
mon collègue jean monnet sur votre
réponse moi j'aimais quelques doutes un
petit peu sur votre orientation niveau
européen quand je vois la lenteur à la
division en ce qui concerne le sujet des
droits voisins portant aussi aussi
cruciaux voilà mais c'est juste une
réflexion propre deuxièmement parce
qu'on parle de concentration c'est que
c'est pas nouveau vous l'avez dit
vous-même puisque depuis longtemps par
le plus de tf1 mais de groupe tf1 en
parle peu décalé mme de groupe canal
gros même
système est annoncé mort on voit aussi
que les choses se font un groupe haïti
sport qui en feront résonner aujourd'hui
en terminant câbles ont deux groupes
est-ce que selon vous les concentrations
se passe toujours aussi mal que ce une
expérience j'avais vécu au sein de itélé
ça c'est ma première question mahzem
question est-ce que vous pensez que
d'envié le public on a aussi des
concentrations france télévisions ces
concentrations radio france ces
concentrations est ce que pour vous dans
l'audiovisuel public on a dansé
concentration toutes les garanties des
meilleurs critères pour l'indépendance
va parler d'eux pendant la liberté
pardon et la pluralité des journalistes
oui mais à écouter pour répondre à votre
deuxième partie de la question moi je
crois que
le salé sucré 6 6 1 6 1
j'allais chiffre d'affaires.le
tf1 m6 rtl ça fait 3 4 milliards de
chiffre d'affaires
l'ensemble télé france télévisions radio
france en fait 3,6 donc c'est kif kif
voilà le monde enthousiaste vient du
fait que j'ai enseigné pendant cinquante
ans et que
j'essaye de séduire mon public ou eux
même de choquer parfois je sais que je
choque certains de deux sénateurs ici
présent bien que je bref
ou pas tous bons
le problème c'est que le csa pour
qu'olivier maistre vous l'a dit n'est
pas fait pour contrôler la limite auriel
d'échelle
ce faire le juge du beau et du bien
comme il a dit ah sinon si si on dit il
faut pas que tel j'aime raconter une
chose puisque c'est maintenant public
nous avons été saisis sur le procès qui
a eu lieu ce matin falla le jugement qui
a eu lieu ce matin nous avons été saisis
au cdj m bon voilà
et tout le monde disait c'est
inadmissible ce qui dit je trouve
inadmissible personnellement je vous dis
pas que c'est très bien ce que ce qu'il
a dit mais bon et j'étais président le
sait d'hygiène et et on a répondu à tous
les gens qui nous ont saisis
c'est un
quelqu'un qui a droit à la liberté
d'expression il n'est pas là en tant que
journaliste et là on truque polémiste
si ces propos tombant sous le coup de la
loi de 880 c'est pas de la déontologie
qu'il s'agit c'est de la loi du 181
incitation à la haine raciale et autres
machins comme ça en revanche
nous avons
pris une des saisines parce que
christine kelly
comment dirais-je souris et vêtements et
n'a absolument pas repris le propos de
eric zemmour et là nous avons dit là il
ya un manque 10 anthologique parce que
elle aurait dû dire en tant que
journaliste animatrice du débat
mais d'où tirez-vous ça ou sur quoi vous
appuyez vous l aurez eu simplement dû
elle a réussi le mans dû dire ça
évidemment il y aurait pas répondu ou il
le faut il aurait répondu à côté mais
bon voilà donc voyez que c'est bon moi
je crois vraiment que la liberté parce
que comme disait clemenceau dans les
dents les deux dans les débats sur la
loi de 80
turgot a été condamné parce que le prêt
d'un thé le prêt à intérêt était quelque
chose de condamnable par l'église donc
on n'avait pas le droit de vente et le
ferais intérêts bon ben maintenant vous
voyez donc la liberté d'expression c'est
au coeur c'est au centre de la
démocratie c'est la liberté d'opinion la
démocratie c'est pas une démocratie des
faits on ne vote pas pour des faits on
vote parce qu'on a des opinions on vote
pour différentes raisons extrêmement
divers et variés qui viennent de notre
éducation de notre sociabilité de notre
terreur et celle de nos parents de nos
arrière grands parents tout ce qu'on
veut bon de nos métiers de l'eau
rencontre et on vote à partir de pignons
et lui la démocratie d'opinion elle
existe et donc il faut qu'elle soit le
plus large spectre ces spectres possible
éventail possible et c'est ça mon point
de vue mais que la société puisse
s'emparer
c'est pour ça que j'ai mis sur cet
observatoire même si je sais que
l'europe est très lente mais les lois en
france aussi sont très lentes bon bon
coeur sauf soit elles sont actives et un
coup de fouet à part quelques
quelquefois bon comme c'est arrivé il ya
peu de temps mais
sinon les oies sont très très lente et
surtout le temps qu'on pense à une loi
qu'on fasse la commission invoque la loi
coeur et qu'on ait décret d'application
il peut se passer entre deux et quatre
ans
évelyne renault garabédian derrière son
écran tv line vous entendez le président
monsieur eveno merci de vos
éclaircissements depuis sa création le
conseil de déontologie se présente comme
un tiers de confiance
médiateur un baromètre de l'institut
ipsos qui a été publié en octobre
dernier a indiqué que seulement 16% des
français font confiance aux journalistes
certains disent que cette perte de
confiance peut parfois provenir de
l'appartenance des journalistes à des
médias détenus par des industriels mais
pour d'autres cela provient de
l'utilisation par certains journalistes
de l'opposition pour faire passer sous
couvert d'information des messages
politiques vous êtes un historien comme
vous l'avez dit des médias la défiance
actuelle à l'égard des journalistes qui
concerne également les politiques est en
réalité toutes les institutions est elle
particulièrement plus importante
aujourd'hui est caractérisée par une
très bonne ou bien est ce si en réalité
depuis toujours dans l'essor de la grèce
simplement mes rôles sont davantage
aujourd'hui ou bien les médias
traditionnels n'ont peut-être en plus le
même poids qu'ils avaient avant merci de
vos réponses alors seule réponse qui est
complexe parce que d'abord avant de
lancer le 16e alors je là je parle pas
au nom du cjm encore une fois j'ai
démissionné je n'ai plus aucune fonction
dont cet organisme je leur laisse vivre
leur vie mais bon on avait fait une
étude avec l'ensemble des conseils de
presse en europe la i p e l'association
internationale des conseils de presse en
europe on l'aurait vu demander est ce
que ce qui a une meilleure confiance
quand il ya un conseil de presse le
conseil de déontologie et toutes les
réponses ont été 8 et la france qui
n'avait pas de conseil de déontologie ou
deux côtés de presse était la dernière
classée dans tous les pays européens
pourtant la presse anglaise est pas
spécialement raffiné parfois et c'est
bon et donc voyez il ya il ya vraiment
une liaison bon
il est évident que on a en france une
presse qui s'est fondé sur des
fondements du rapport au politique
que ce soit pas en vente jusqu'à
théophraste renaudot qui était dans la
main de richelieu et louis xiii mais
c'est la révolution française qui marque
sa à la révolution française qui marque
que la la presse est polarisée et
pendant tout le 19e siècle jusqu'à 1
watt 80
c'est le pouvoir politique qui essayent
d'empêcher la presse de s'exprimer ou la
presse qui essaient la révolution de
1830 c'est d'abord une révolution de la
presse c'est d'abord voilà c'est
tiers girardin et compagnie qui qui
lance les typographes dans la rue bon et
ça fait partir le roi bon donc on a une
liaison très politique alors est ce que
la france est parmi les très très très
mal classée c'est pour ça que avec
quelques autres nous pensions que la
création d'un conseil de théologie
permettrait de rétablir et je crois que
le fait de répondre au public ça permet
de rétablir un minimum de confiance mais
ça va être un processus très long le
seul problème c'est que beaucoup de gens
pensent que on va répondre sur la
question politique c'est à dire que est
ce que zemmour arrêt breux a raison de
dire ça ou est-ce que tu as aboaf a
raison de dire ça
c'est nous le contenu l'important la
déontologie c'est le processus de
fabrication de collecte de ces de
diffusion de l'information qui doit être
fait selon un cahier des charges qui est
dans les cales dans les chartes de
déontologie qu'on retrouve par tout bon
qu'elles sont à peu près tout les mêmes
bon c'est c'est pour ça que la
déontologie la concentration ça très peu
le rapport
je prends souvent l'exemple qui fait qui
fait hurler mes amis journalistes je
vais en avoir de moins en mois ci mais
coûte
que je dis c'est pas la taille du
poulailler qui fait que le poulet
fermier c'est le respect du cahier des
charges d'élevage du poulet fermier et
et que un poulet et 2000 paul 2000
poulet pardon ou trois poulets si le
cahier des charges est bien respectée
par ce film il poule il a droit à
l'appellation poulet fermier la qualité
journalistique c'est le cahier des
charges de la déontologie et c'est là
encore une fois ou alors
la plus grande concentration de journée
c'est la fpc france télévisions c'est
radio france et puis ensuite on va dans
les dents les quotidiens ou ouest-france
le monde le figaro etc bon voila c
est ce que je crois que depuis très très
longtemps madame la sénatrice pour vous
répondre précisément depuis le milieu du
xixème siècle
les français ne sont jamais contents de
leur presse jamais ils n'ont jamais été
contents de leur presse
monique de marco même si
merci monsieur est venu vous avez
présidé le pôle concentration pluralisme
et développement des états généraux de
la presse tu es tu participes à
l'instance consultative des aides à la
presse où le mandat d'aurélie filippetti
ministre de la culture
pourriez vous nous faire part de ce qui
vous semble le plus pertinent à réformer
dans les aides à la presse
ne pensez vous pas qu'il est urgent de
conditionner l'octroi de ces aides à une
forme juridique garanties d'indépendance
pour les rédactions par exemple alors
je lui une forme juridique
d'indépendance des rédactions moi je
vous dis d'abord que je croyais pas
l'indépendance des rédactions
puisqu'elles sont payés par un
entrepreneur qui voit là
vous aviez niel mathieu pigasse et
compagnie à ligne chaque année 50
millions d'euros pour payer la rédaction
du monde
il ya donc évidemment un lien de
dépendance
directe
donc par contre c'est une très grande
liberté parce que parce que la rédaction
du monde a obtenu depuis fort longtemps
de pouvoir voter sur le directeur de la
rédaction de pouvoir avoir un certain
nombre d'instances il ya une société des
rédacteurs extrêmement vivante la
première fournée en france en 1951 pour
soutenir le patron de l'époque hubert
beuve-méry
c'est la rédaction qui soutenait le
patron c'est assez drôle bon et et ainsi
de suite ah bon il ya il ya là eu par
négociation par
faire
un statut juridique je sais que beaucoup
de syndicats enfin le snj le snj cgt et
quelques autres réclament un statut
juridique pour garantir l'indépendance
des rédactions
bon courage franchement bon courage pour
trouver la formule juridique qui soit
acceptable par le conseil
constitutionnel
de trouver là là là vraiment l'un dépend
ce que ça veut dire alors
soit on fige et rédaction dans un état
un ça c'est aussi une surtout on va est
figé pression n'aura plus grand dit
touché
bon qu'elle élève mais quel est
véritablement l'intérêt d'avoir un
statut juridique si ce n'est de pouvoir
ester en justice
d'accord mais les syndicats peuvent le
faire mais pas besoin d'un nouveau un
nouveau truc spécial
je pensais à toute une série de
problèmes par exemple puisqu'on va
revenir encore à monsieur bolloré il va
et va croire à force que bien que nous
soyons breton tous les deux je n'aime
pas la bretagne
mais bon on pourrait très bien lutté
contre bolloré en se servant de 2 2 ce
qui a juridiquement dans les autres loi
qui ne concerne pas les médias comme par
exemple les abus de biens sociaux
quand sur bolloré fait un procès de
bâillon à des des médias tout petit
bastamag ou à des très gros médias mais
en leur demandant 50 millions d'euros au
tribunal de commerce vont etc on
pourrait comme tous les frais de justice
et tous les frais judiciaires d'avocats
et cetera sont payés par l'entreprise
bolloré ou par vise un dix on pourrait
très bien c'est un abus de bien social
et
détournement de l'objectif social de
l'entreprise ou abus de bien social
quand on fait payer par l'entreprise un
procès qui ne concerne que monsieur
bolloré lui-même en fait et parce que on
dit du mal de lui dans certains médias
c'est bon on a parlé de trafic
d'influencé moi je veux bien mais trafic
d'influencé comment prouver du trafic
d'influencé on revient au même
c'est enfin
je sais que les syndicats tiennent
beaucoup les syndicats de journalistes
tiennent beaucoup à la création d'une
entité juridique et sais pas quoi qu'ils
consacreraient l'indépendance
rédactionnelle des rédactions moi j'ai
toujours très peur de 6g les rédactions
il faut que laisser les rédactions sur
mobile le plus mobile possible parce
qu'il faut s'adapter en permanence et
donc figé rédaction ça pose des
problèmes ensuite ça va poser des
problèmes sociaux et des problèmes bon
et c'est économiques qui vont moi je
trouve que c'est pour pas grand chose
alors qu'ils allaient syndicats qui
peuvent intervenir alors qu'ils aient
les sociétés de rédacteurs qui peuvent
intervenir qui ont des personnalités
juridiques qui sont des associations
mais elles peuvent très bien se
retourner contre leurs patrons si elles
en ont envie bon bref mais je sais que
suis ben voilà il ya jean pas tellement
l'intérêt de la chose
pardon pour vote
il hérite de l'état oui les acteurs et à
excuser moi les aides de l'état
oui elles ont beaucoup augmenté avec les
états généraux de la presse à l'époque
de nicolas sarkozy ce qui était une
énorme de faire attention au temps parce
qu'il est déjà 16h25 normalement on
s'arrête à 16h30 à bord d un petit peu
mais si vous pouvez être
rapide dans vos réponses les les aides
de l'état son temps à la presse sont en
régression on avait fait introduire avec
reco livier maistre un syndrome de
critères parce que maintenant il ya des
conventions qui sont signés entre les
bas qui devraient être signés parce
qu'elles sont pas beaucoup de signer
mais il y en a quelques-unes de signer
et parmi celles ci il était d'adhérer un
à un organisme déontologiques et ses
experts bon les aides de l'état des
dizaines de et à la presse elles sont en
voie de résorption à part celles qui
sont immobiles parce qu'on va pas
commencer à toucher aux taux de tva par
exemple à 2,1 pour cent ça c'est bon
tout le reste c'est l'aide à la poste
bon au transport postal comme il n'y
aura bientôt plus de transport postal y
aura plus besoin d'aidé la poste a
transporté la presse
que l'aide à la distribution comme ya de
moins en moins de distribution alors
bien sûr il faut apurer presstalis ça a
coûté déjà plusieurs centaines de
millions d'euros et ça va en coûter
encore mais c'est tout ça c'est en voie
de disparition les imprimeries par les
imprimeries il y en aura de moins en
moins puisqu'il y aura vraiment failli à
l'image en moins de papier ou et que
maintenant
riccobono imprime tous les journaux
nationaux
et maintenant je distribue aussi les
journaux nationaux donc les aides de
l'état les conditionner les conditionner
comment au respect de quoi au respect de
l'indépendance des rédactions là encore
une fois bon voilà bah oui mais comment
comment enfin je suis pas juriste mais
je vois mal comment on pourrait
trouver la formule juridique qui qui qui
ferait qui permettrait cela sylvie
robert
oui merci monsieur le président
rapidement je vais revenir monsieur sur
vos premiers propos vous avez dit à deux
types de concentrations concentration
économique
on va parler de tf1 m6 rtl qui est plus
dans une démarche défensive et là je
m'arrête un instant et je vous pose la
première question aura 2 est-ce que vous
pensez que ça a du sens par rapport aux
gars femmes et à ce qu'il représente
aujourd'hui
est la deuxième type de concentration
qui est une concentration plutôt
offensive de type politique à vous
entendre est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas
dire aujourd'hui que tous les phénomènes
de concentration
ces phénomènes ne sont pas nouveaux vous
l'avez dit vous-même mais ils sont d'une
autre nature et à vous entendre là je
vous entendu est-ce que les phénomènes
de concentration aujourd'hui ne serait
pas justement de nature politique parce
que derrière ce sont des industriels qui
d'ailleurs dont ce n'est pas le métier
initial on le sait
ce ne sont pas des hommes de
l'information et si on considère que la
concentration de type économique mais
vous allez me dire si vous êtes d'accord
n'a pas de sens parce que les gars
femmes représentent aujourd'hui une
telle puissance et j'ai regardé vos
chiffres que finalement ça n'a pas de
sens qu'au niveau français on puisse
être encore dans une démarche comme ça
vous me prenez bien les concentrations
d'aujourd'hui serait donc plutôt
offensive et politique et je reprends la
vôtre eh bien je ne suis pas d'accord
avec vous madame la sénatrice parce que
c'est une je vous ai dit que c'était
c'était une concentration défensive tf1
m6 rtl défensif pour garder un petit peu
de public un petit peu de ils vont pas
concurrencer netflix vous inquiétez pas
vous voyez bien que salto comment ça
marche et salto l'aller 3 pour les trois
français réunis dans le sénat à peine
700 milles mais si ça a un sens c'est un
sens économique pour l'entreprise pour
les autres qu'est ce qu'on fait de m6
bertelsmann a décidé de se désengager la
télé européenne et de ne garder que de
la télé en allemagne bon ils ont vendu
rtl belgique
aof groupe rossel ils veulent vendre rtl
m6 france bon si c'est pas tf1 qu'il
achète ce sera quelqu'un d'autre mais
berthen n'en veut plus
voilà c'est terminé pour ils ont tiré
les leçons il considère qu' il faut se
replier sur le marché allemand c'est
leur problème ben oui mais je suis c'est
bon alors c'est pas une conscience
politique pourquoi parce que les
rédactions seront pas mélanger
certainement pas les rédactions sur ceux
de même que les programmes ce serait
suicidaire
je vous ai pas dit mais attendez ce
serait suffisait de de faire des
rédactions fusionner parce que sont pas
sur les mêmes créneaux elles sont pas
sur les horaires elles sont passées et
que j'étais bon alors
ma question est ce que est ce que les
concentrations telles que vous les 10
c'est en tout cas les énoncés là et
notamment celle de tf1 a du sens
aujourd'hui n'est économiquement oui et
ne pensez vous pas oui parce que
parce que il ya d'autres phénomènes qui
s'opère avec derrière les impacts que
vous avez vous même énoncé ce ne sont
pas aujourd'hui des concentrations qui
sont d'une autre nature et qui prennent
le devant de la scène ou à dire de
nature politique et offensive non
je vous ai dit oui ça a du sens pour
l'entreprise tf1 m6 de regrouper ses
forces de faire des économies d'échelle
de fer etc
mais évidemment que ils vont pas
remplacer amazon ou netflix demain mais
ça a du sens quand même pour
l'entreprise française dont je vous
parle faut bien voir que il ya deux sens
un mondial est un français c'est pas la
même chose
vincent capo-canellas ce
un sens
oui président bonjour bonjour à tous
merci d'abord monsieur le professeur de
votre propos qui tire roboratif d'y
amener de la clarté mais qui nous invite
à une forme de simplicité dans ce qu'on
pourrait nommer me reprendre du point de
vue législatif pour autant je voudrais
essayer de prolonger avec votre
réflexion à ce que vous ludique en gros
si je caricature et j'ai conscience de
le faire que la concentration des médias
n'est pas le vrai sujet que le sujet que
le pluralisme que il d'ailleurs beaucoup
à fait à côté internet mais en même
temps vous témoignez de votre expérience
difficile
à ces news donc je me demande si la
conclusion de l'observatoire vous nous
proposez n'est pas un instrument
relativement faibles donc alors sans
vouloir tout traduire dans la loi et
sans être trop coercitif s'agissant du
statut des rédactions sk par un stand de
principe ou d'obligations d'adhérer à un
observatoire avait une façon de
retrouver à des principes à mettre dans
le dans le corps législatif applicable
qui donnerait plus de force à votre à
votre raisonnement
oui peut-être si si les parlementaires
et les sénateurs en premier c'est s'en
saisissent et décide on a réclamé le
soutien des parlementaires et des
députés comme des sénateurs pour
lorsqu'on a créé le sait les iem on a eu
une réponse
extrêmement faibles si je puis dire pour
ne pas dire nulles
donc on s'est passé de la représentation
parlementaire pour créer le truc parce
qu' il fallait qu'on considérait qu'il
fallait le créer bon
c'est comme ça
moi j'ai bien sûr que ce sera faible
mais moi je vois sur le long terme bien
que je sois un vieux monsieur est que je
ne verrai pas le goût de la chose
j'ai je vois sur le long terme et sur le
long terme c'est l'important c'est de
conforter la société démocratique c'est
de faire en sorte que la société
démocratique qui en europe est attaqué
par plusieurs endroits à la fois par les
gaffes à part les trolls par les machins
par les trolls internationaux ou
nationaux ou tous à conforter la
solitude démocratique et la conforter
une partie du confort qu'on peut lui
afin de lui comment dire de la
confortation je peux que m'en ont dit
oui
ce serait de lui donner les moyens de
faire savoir
à ses jouets pénale qui a et on mange
tout à fait d'accord avec lui là dessus
comme quoi vous savez je suis pas
certains traits de l'ultralibéral de
chômage et de misère mais je suis pas
psy pas tant que ça je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec evs et louis plenel sur le
droit savoir à il faut que les citoyens
puissent savoir alors bien sûr c'est pas
la solution miracle 1 ça n'a aucune
solution miracle mais je sais bien que
vous êtes des législateurs donc vous
avez envie de légiférer c'est votre job
mais quand même vous savez aussi que
l'abus des lois traîne
bon bon ça ça pose des problèmes aussi
je moi je vois je vois pas encore une
fois je vois pas comment on peut faire
que
une loi disent les rédactions doivent
être indépendantes de l'actionnaire
cédant c'est dans le tout les textes
dans la loi de 86 ça y est mais si bien
sûr que si je peux vous j'ai pas j'ai
pas le temps parce que je vais encore me
faire reprendre par le président mais je
peux vous citer la loi de 86 c'est dans
la convention collective des
journalistes ils ont le droit de refuser
et c'est l'actionnaire de 86 n'a pas le
droit d'imposer et c'est bon donc tout
ça ça existe c'est pas la peine de créer
encore un organisme supra je sais pas
quoi
donner à l'art comme des pouvoirs de
garantir l'indépendance des rédactions
c'est ce style imagé rebondir quand même
source que à la fois les deux dernières
questions puisque ce que vous dites
parce que dans votre propos introductif
vous avez dit il ya deux logiques on
s'est concentré sur la logique
économique et puis la logique
démocratique que vous avez alors
peut-être raccourcie de la présentation
on a eu le sentiment que vous opposiez
en disant par exemple se regardent tf1
m6 c'est une logique économique si on
regarde
le groupe vend 10 et
par rapport à lagardère par exemple
c'est plus une logique démocratique
c'est un propos qui sont en mai j'allais
vous dire de manière provocatrice parce
que vous avez un ton un peu provocateur
je me permet de rentrer dans le même si
vous qui le dites parce que quand on
écoute 2010 ils vous disent c'est une
logique économique nous voulons fonder
un grand groupe international
c'est exactement en même temps qu'est ce
qui est si on est plusieurs à intervenir
là dessus parce que c'est parce que
c'est une problématique qui nous
intéresse de savoir qu'est ce qui permet
de définir
quels sont les critères qui soit
vraiment qu'ils n'ont pas soit pas
subjectif mais qui soit juridiquement
opposable si je peux dire est ainsi qu
est ce qui permet de dire qu'on est plus
dans la logique économique mais qu'on
est de réagir démocratique que le le
cadre démocratique où l'esprit
démocratique qui doit prévaloir est
dépassé dans un cas ou dans un autre
c'est très compliqué et pardon juste
pour vous complétez ma question qui doit
dire mais voilà moi ce que j'ai essayé
de vous dire c'est que c'est
certainement pas la loi
c'est même pas aux organismes de
régulation qui sont les autorités
indépendantes experts pourquoi enfin je
dis que je ne dis pas que
la logi bolloré elle n'est pas une
logique aussi
économiques
je n'y crois pas je n'y crois pas
pourquoi parce que j'ai vu françois coty
en 1920 à acheter figaro puis en 23
rachel gaulois puis en 28 créé l'ami du
peuple et puis en 34 faire faillite
françois coty qui était un grand
parfumeur à l'époque et qui avait fait
fortune avec la forêt et qui en face is
an ces journaux a fait baisser le lait
les ventes de 90 %
90 % en douze ans pour le figaro costaud
un bon -90%
j'y crois pas moi bolloré il veut sailly
là il a sont ses porte-flingues l'actuel
m'enfin bon voilà très bien mais est-ce
que ça va durer est ce qu'on va faire
une loin pour que monsieur bolloré vais
avoir 70 ans dans un mois ou deux mois
je sais plus bon il est il sera pas
éternelle comme vous et moi et donc est
ce qu'on va faire une loi pour voilà le
problème c'est que sa peau mois pour moi
ça ne pose pas véritablement de problème
démocratique ce qui pose le problème de
la liberté des rédactions encore une
fois c'est ça qui m'importe mais que
l'éventail de la démocratie
s'élargissent de l'extrême droite à
l'extrême gauche ça ne me pose pas de
problème démocratique ça me paraît tout
à fait logique que ye l'humanité et que
quand je trouve dommage que les insoumis
et pas réussi à faire de leur télé le
média une vraie télé je trouve ça
dommage même si je ne suis pas du tout
de bons jeux voilà non mais d'hervé je
trouve ça dommage et mais il était aussi
qu'un rite aid caricaturaux moi je me
suis acheté invité pour un débat encore
sur la concentration pluralisme et cgt
il y avait il y avait deux trotskiste un
communiste
et puis edwy plenel et laurent mauduit
et puis enfin bon bref c'était puis moir
bah oui mais c'était un débat à la
shoah ont fait pire sur ces news le
problème sur ces news c'est là où on
retombe sur le pluralisme interne c'est
que j'ai assisté à un débat l'autre jour
avec monsieur bock côté et de l'autre
côté en face de lui il y avait un
journaliste qui publie dans un journal
d'extrême droite
voyez que le débat était extrêmement
conflictuel
dernière question de notre reporter
david
oui
il ya la tentation cela on est dans les
débats entre nous deux pignons ou alors
d'appréciation des enjeux et je suis
très étonné que que ce qui a fait
consensus républicain de la droite à la
gauche de
toutes obédiences religieuses toutes
obédiences et une nuance de l'échiquier
politique
issu de la résistance est à dire de la
république
aujourd'hui
soit 6,6 relativiser parce que quand
vous parlez de l'extrême droite certes
ça veut tout dire et rien dire mais en
tous les cas n'est pas une opinion dans
la république et depuis 45 et après
vichy le racisme etc mais c'est sans
chez deloitte 81 ans considéré oui non
mais beaucoup d'accord sauf que on parle
là de 2,2 de la liberté d'opinion et
vous en gros vous dit tout ce qu'on a
envie de dire est possible or non et ça
il ya des régulations et y compris dans
les conventions avec les chaînes de
télévision et cet écrit c'est ce sont
des engagements contractuels je sais
avec voilà donc où on les fait sauter on
pense que je sais pas quoi et qu'une
chaîne youtube c'est la même chose une
chaîne de mélenchon l'umad d'un fasciste
qui a monté sa chaîne et encore elles
sont régulés par youtube c'est la même
chose que quand le csa
sur les retient et sur la tnt
oak trail chembond donc ça c'est un
débat je pense quand même qu'il est
qu'il est très important
sur la sur la question du statut j'ai
entendu votre opinion vous pensez que
que c'est pas tellement
l'indépendance d'action comme ça parce
que ça pourrait s'appeler la liberté
puis ça vous irait plus la liberté des
rédactions mais
la réflexion à avoir je pense que que
nous devront l'avoir et effectivement il
ya des choses inutiles mais chose
impossible c'était mais on sent bien que
il y a deux droits individuels forts qui
ont été créés pour protéger les
journalistes le droit de cession et la
clause de conscience et qu' il n'y a
aucun droit collectif à part celui des
syndicats m'enfin les syndicats ne
représentent pas une rédaction il ya
beaucoup de syndicats ils peuvent être
divergents et on n'a jamais donné aux
syndicats le statut d'être le
représentant exclusif d'une rédaction
voire même de sa direction ce qu'une
rédaction cd dirigeants de la rédaction
et les journalistes donc vous vous avez
répondu mais
comment vous dire est ce que vous pensez
pas que est-ce que plutôt vous qu'est ce
que vous pensez
du fait quand même de réfléchir un peu
plus à quelle que soit l'ampleur du
danger qu on apprécie vous un peu moins
que moi extra à un statut juridique plus
fort
pour assurer la liberté des rédactions
alors ça j'ai pas eu le temps de me dire
parce que c'était dans le papier mais il
était beaucoup trop long
moi je suis je trouve que la loi
brachard de 1935 keefe a créé la clause
de cession est la cause de conscience à
a pas vus très bien les choses c'est à
dire que la clause de cession et
l'automatique dès qu'on change
actionnaires tout le monde est heureux
de partir et il faut payer bon même s'il
n'ya pas de changement éditorial
quand
hersant a racheté à provocante pouvoir
acheter à boussac quand boussac a
racheté à madame côte nord et à nous
gaver et elle était sa de monsieur coty
le figaro est resté de droite
conservateur machin etc bon ça n'a pas
changé et il ya eu cause de clause de
cession à chaque fois
la clause de conscience et les jamais
utilisée elle a été pro tools 2,3 depuis
1935 de trois personnes aussi l'utiliser
à chaque fois ça ça n'a pas marché donc
moi je serais pour transformer ces deux
clauses en une seule qui serait une
clause de conscience collective en cas
de changement de ligne éditoriale
voiliers et la la c'est là où la liberté
de la rédaction pourrait s'impliquer
parce que
oui mais
c'est pas c'est pas sanctuariser
l'indépendance des rédactions nation
qu'on est d'accord bien sûr sur plein de
choses monsieur assouline bien sûr ne
croyez pas que je sois un méchant
non on est d'accord sur plein de choses
mais il faut voir comment on peut
légiférer je trouve qu'une clause de
conscience collective serait bien plus
intelligente que ces deux clauses de
cession et de conscience qu'ils sont
d'un côté
ça ça augmente le prix de vente parce
que il ya les vieux journaliste je me
suis là leur berceau les qui six mois
avant la retraite par avec 33 voix de
d'ancienneté bon voilà poc le tranquille
bon et puis la clause de conscience qui
n'est il faut prouver et qu'il ya eu
changement nini taurian mais un
journaliste tout seul c'est très
difficile je me souviens de michèle et
michel le jeu commence après qui a fait
ça au monde dans les années soixante dix
en dix ans de pig babe mairie est plus
là c'est devenu un journal communiste et
c'est bon il a été débouté
bon c'est
on ne peut pas enfin voilà donc
effectivement là on pourrait avoir
quelque chose de très intéressant et qui
pourrait être soutenu par les syndicats
parce que syndicats ils font ils se
battent pour faire appliquer la clause
de cession ils soutiennent généralement
quand il ya besoin s'il ya besoin d'une
clause de conscience donc oui là et je
sais pas une espérons qu'ils étaient
licenciés semble-t-il injustement
d'après elle elle est soutenue par les
syndicats pour les syndicats vont en
justice à ses côtés ça paraît tout à
fait logique
merci monsieur eveno pour 7 et pour ses
explications cette parole libre
qui éclaire et notre notre commission on
avait une certaine franchise de ventre
et une illusion que dans
vos prises de position dont merci pour
les pions pour votre participation de
cet après midi puis on sera bien sûr si
vous n'avez pas pu développer certains
aspects je vous ai senti frustré oui
j'en suis désolé certains moments mais
nenê oui je vais prolonger d'un quart
des victimes mais n'hésitez pas à nous
envoyer un écrit si vous voulez revenir
qu'elle plus précisément sur tel ou tel
point que vous nous merci d'avoir
accueilli parce que c'est toujours un
plaisir de vous voir merci
[Musique]